[Music]
hey everybody what's going on yep it's
sunday it's the sunday before memorial
day yeah we got to go out tonight
yeah we're going out tonight so i'm
gonna tell everybody like right now
we're talking about the godfather today
because we watched it last night but
yeah that thing is like three hours i
was gonna watch part one and part two
last night but we didn't start until 7
30 or 8. so by the time it was over i
was like too sleepy to like stay up and
watch the other one so probably tomorrow
we'll have to do a sidetrack show
because we won't have time to like watch
the movie before the show tomorrow but
we'll get around to it it's three hours
but it doesn't feel like three hours it
really does it goes by fast it really
does got a really good edit
yeah i mean big time yeah this i mean
okay this is a classic flick i mean yeah
that's the thing about it is there
really anything i mean obviously we're
going to talk about it but it's like is
there really anything that we can say
about it that hasn't been said before
because i kind of feel like this
what does this have this has one of the
highest like rotten tomatoes scores i've
ever seen of any film ever i think it's
like 99
so it's like universal acclaim um and
pretty much i think
you know even the what what do you call
it like the national film institute or
american film institute or whatever this
is like their second great greatest
american film after citizen kane um you
know what i mean and i so i kind of feel
like
i don't think everyone's seen it maybe
like especially younger people now i had
seen it when i was younger
but i hadn't seen it for many years so
in case we didn't um mention it i mean i
know we did mention it but louis
hernandez yeah uh sent us the trilogy
like the blue rays
and this is kind of like well this is
like the 50th anniversary right because
this came out in 1972 originally so it's
been restored because for a long time
like the negatives were all shitty and
everything like that so they had to like
uh coppola had to restore it though this
looks like years ago yeah it looks
fantastic i mean
every frame of this looks uh looks
gorgeous if you haven't seen this if
you're if you're younger and you haven't
seen this you gotta see this this is uh
this is the gangster version of
apocalypse now
now there's there's a uh we got a viewer
who i'll talk to offline or online
sometimes his name is xanada he's over
in new mexico i think it was in nevada i
don't remember arizona anyway uh he had
never seen apocalypse now he was he
isn't even even really a big movie fan
he i i told him to get that apocalypse
now redo because they re-released that
thing and it's got some
stuff put back into it he said that was
the best movie he's ever seen he got
addicted to it he was watching that
thing like every day for like [ __ ] a
couple weeks just loving that movie this
is a movie like that
if
it's a movie that you can kind of get
immersed in
and
you kind of see more and more in it
every time
because some [ __ ] happens you don't know
what happens until it until it happens
and you go oh that's why that happened
because stuff is out of out of order
they're using gangster skills
they'll just kill some dude you got
why'd they kill that dude and then later
you realize oh he he could have he was
the only one that could have known
so he was the suspect you know and then
later on they'll they they'll say how
they knew or you know they'll talk about
what happened why they killed that guy
it's just good flick man a lot of detail
a lot of tension detail looking
tarantino wishes he made this movie a
lot of [ __ ] tarantino does
he's kind of ape in this kind of like a
ghetto version of this this is [ __ ]
classy [ __ ] this is a good gangster
movie it's classy [ __ ] yeah thank you
zach
fun fact today is the birthday of the
series cinematographer gordon willis and
can we all take a minute to appreciate
how gorgeous these films are yeah they
really really are i really i
particularly love like the contrast
between the sort of like interior scenes
like the very iconic like first scene
where everyone's coming in like asking
uh asking the godfather like for favors
and stuff and then contrasted with like
the real bright sunlit like wedding
scenes but yeah they really really did i
mean it's it's a beautiful looking thing
and i think they did that i kind of feel
like i read somewhere that he was trying
to make everything look blocked like a
like a painting kind of you know what i
mean which you can kind of really see
when you watch the movie camp guy says
best scenes just about everyone yeah
yeah i had forgotten how
there is no dull scenes no i mean it
just moves and this movie covers
10 years yeah in three hours yeah in the
40s 40s i think maybe early 50s it's
1945 to 1955 is what the time span is
the general story is uh marlon brando
plays the godfather
and they kind of establish his character
and what he's all about he's kind of
like the local justice outside of them
outside of the law you know if looking
the law fails you you can go to him and
he'll
you know [ __ ] some people up because
what they did your daughter that kind of
stuff
and um
he they show some gangster [ __ ] happened
you know him [ __ ]
showing his top dog or whatever and then
um
the main gist of the movie is that the
five these five gangster families mafia
families around new york and new jersey
the new york area
offer don corleone this deal they want
him to get involved in
drug trafficking
and he says no no thank you i don't want
to do it
and because he said no
they put out a hit on him they tried to
kill him but he survives a hit
and then while he's wounded his sons
are trying to retaliate against the hit
and keep their
keep their mafia empire together and it
goes sideways many times and they're at
war for years against these other
families
and then finally
the good son out of them becomes uh
the dawn and how anyhow he does [ __ ] and
and then he kind of wins the war in the
end
and [ __ ] establishes [ __ ] it ends
with him [ __ ]
establishing order within his own family
and then it sets it up for the sequel
it's a good movie good movie now
specifically um they have
don corleone well you know they they put
a hit out on him
because at the whole meeting that they
had where he was just like yeah i don't
want to do the drug trafficking sunny uh
played by james khan yeah he kind of
like speaks up and is kind of so he kind
of like
i guess when him speaking up which the
donna's like mad about
um says to the other gangsters it's like
oh probably that son would be open to
doing the drug trafficking so we need to
get the don out of the way so that we
can get him in charge and [ __ ] like that
but the thing about it i mean the theme
of the whole entire movie i mean there's
a lot of other stuff going on obviously
there's like tons of characters and tons
of like backstabbing and tons of all
kind of stuff going on it's like a mini
series almost it is um but it's really
well controlled like it really does i
was watching like one
kind of breakdown of it earlier and they
said you know it's every cause has an
effect like even if it doesn't happen
until like years later and you're just
like oh that's what that was setting up
you know what i mean so it's like really
great the way they do that but the
interesting thing about it i mean sort
of the the through line of the whole
thing is michael the good son played by
al pacino who's [ __ ] great in this
yeah uh young al pacino a very young
alba yeah he was not completely unknown
but he was pretty unknown around this
time or like not you know obviously not
the iconic star that he would become
really it was kind of like this film
that sort of like set him off into like
superstar especially in the gangster
area the tough guy this sends him down
the tough guy path even though he's a
little guy
well and that's why the studio didn't
want him yeah
one because he was unknown
and two because they said well he's so
short yeah i think he's what 5'4 they
actually did like say that they didn't
want him it works though because those
dudes in real life were short a lot of
those second gangster guys were short
they weren't they weren't tall guys yeah
so it did i think it worked
i think it worked good
well there was there was differences in
them too
um you know that [ __ ] wasn't done with
braun they had they had soldier class
and officer class
thinkers and people that had money it
wasn't a universal type
one size fits all the gangster world you
know um it was three what i liked about
it is that the story is about three suns
two italian ones and an adopted
irish-american one it's sunny
uh tom and he's the conciliary he's like
their lawyer they had him uh educated as
a lawyer
and then uh what was his name again
michael
sonny's kind of just like
regular italian goomba kind of [ __ ]
hot head but he's
he's a good guy he's just a [ __ ] hot
head tom
tom is too laid back too chilled out but
real cerebral
and um
what's the guy's name again [ __ ]
michael michael yeah mike michael is uh
he's not involved in any gangster [ __ ]
all right he's he's yeah he was like a
war hero he was a marine
and he didn't want anything to do with
it he was a marine officer he was a he
was a he was a
captain so he had already had command
skills
and he had some military understanding
because of the hit on his dad he decides
to get in the game
and
he rises to the top of the three
tom couldn't serve because he was
adopted and he wasn't italian but he was
high up in there
um sonny was just too hot-headed he he
got he got killed he was too impulsive
too impulsive he didn't think things
through
uh so you know al pacino was the one
that [ __ ] rose to the top and he he
became in the end because he was very
calm and calculated
and cold
yeah well and you can kind of see that
like from the beginning even when he was
like still the good guy and he's still
like i don't really want to get involved
that's just my family it's not me
but
as circumstances went on like over the
years he ended up being
you know the one that was i guess
because in that way he was like the cl
he was sort of like
the most similar to his father
even though his father
wasn't real into like just putting out
hits on people and so he was much more
family based much more honor based where
it seemed like michael was much more i
don't want to say like selfish but he
was just more power hungry for the sake
of power where i feel like vito corleone
was not yeah you know what i'm saying
michael michael connor really got into
it when his dad got killed and then he's
he he decides he wants to to avenge him
personally so they set up with this
mission where he's dad got shot he was
yeah i got shot he didn't die he didn't
die later that's right uh he was going
to avenge the shooting uh and they have
a big scene where they sneak a gun into
a bathroom at a restaurant where they're
going to meet up and he meets with a bad
cop and what was the name of that other
gangster
i think his name was salazar
and that's guy the guy played by salazar
was really good
i don't know the name of that actor
um because i because i'm fluent in
portuguese they had a scene where he
goes he excuses himself in front of the
cop he says look we're going to talk in
italian
and they start talking and salazar i
think is what his name was
tells him he says look i had the utmost
he says it in italian but it's there's
no subtitles he says i had the most the
utmost respect for don corleone but
let's be honest
his thinking is old-fashioned
and then he he said um
i'm not you know i don't remember the
exact order he says i'm not doing this
by my own will they're making me do this
all right [ __ ] i'm the hunted one
and he goes if we can get this behind us
and you join up with me
later on we can avenge your father's
assassin or assassination attempt
and that's not in there the subtitles
weren't there but i was like okay so but
michael doesn't really believe him i
guess and kills him anyway later on
uh
but maybe michael's like oh so you're
going to betray you're you're you're
going to betray the guy's telling you to
do this i can't trust you either that
might have been that also it might have
been the red well yeah because i mean if
somebody's going to rat on that person
like to tell you some [ __ ] then if they
come over to your side then they might
rat on you yeah so it's probably not
good anyway yeah it's not a good type of
person to have a route then later on you
find out
you find out
in this big meeting when don corleone
recovers the meeting between the five
families
[ __ ]
uh if michael's there he watches the
whole thing happen turns out it was the
[ __ ] head of the whole dawns that did
it that the organization ordered that
hit it wasn't that salazo guy so he was
telling the truth
they made him do it
but um
yeah that was a good touch so and so
really what i'm trying to say is in the
movie
there aren't any really good guys or bad
guys it's all guys just
flipping and flopping depending on
whatever the power dynamics were at the
time they're just trying to survive all
of them in this
inner intertwined
mess of [ __ ]
leverage a lot of leverage on each other
you know and orders
and
rank and rank hierarchies and stuff it's
a good flip
thank you again zach
uh he's the one the cinematographer uh
who started that dim contrasty lighting
trend in 70s movies basically and that
look appeals to me so much i don't know
why he also shot clue to he's still
trying to get us to talk about we will i
promise like one of these days but the
thing about well okay the thing about
the godfather i was watching this
documentary earlier about like the
making of this
and
this movie it's amazing
because you know how sometimes you hear
about movies and it's just like oh my
god it was like such a [ __ ] like
behind the scenes um and then when it
comes out it's like obviously it was a
[ __ ] this was like a massive
[ __ ] [ __ ] and yet it came out
like as one of the most brilliant i mean
everything about this was like a [ __ ]
hassle it's like they didn't i think
they didn't even want
francis ford coppola at the time he was
known but not like francis ford coppola
you know what i mean
um and none of the actors that francis
ford coppola wanted
um the studio didn't want them like i
said they didn't want al pacino they
wanted somebody more known they wanted
like ryan o'neal or somebody like that
because he'd just been in love story
um and they absolutely did not want um
they absolutely did not want marlon
brando because one at this point in his
career he was kind of a little bit of a
has-been
and two he was notoriously difficult to
work with
uh so they didn't really want him to be
in it but francis ford copley like
insisted you know what i mean and the
thing about it too was that
i feel like coppola was really adamant
and he um co-wrote the screenplay with
mario puzo who wrote the original novel
and they were adamant that they really
wanted all italian-american actors and
you know obviously the producer kind of
wanted italian-american director as well
like to make it as authentic as possible
but the first thing that producers
wanted to do because the novel which i
think i read but it was like a really
long time ago
the novel was like a massive massive
massive success um mario puzo
interestingly before he wrote this book
i guess a book that he had written
previously i can't remember what it's
called but it had i think the video the
vito corleone character in there like as
a like a little side character and he
thought that was it was an interesting
enough character they could write a
whole novel about it but he knew
absolutely jack [ __ ] about the mob
so he like went out to vegas and he hung
out at like some you know some of the
casinos there that like where mob people
were and was like kind of talking to
people that like knew all the stories
and [ __ ] like that and wrote the thing
about that and it was like a huge
[ __ ] success which was good because
he was broke at the time and he had all
these gambling debts and he needed some
[ __ ] money so
the producers like i guess it was
paramount and paramount was in big
trouble at the time too well a lot of
movie studios were because everybody was
like watching tv and people weren't
going to movies that much anymore and
paramount had like kind of put out some
movies including another gangster movie
that hadn't really done all that well so
like nobody cares about gangster movies
like we don't really want to make
another one necessarily but because the
book was so successful they're like oh
okay maybe
so initially they wanted something that
they could make for this is hilarious
they wanted to make this movie for two
and a half million dollars and just make
it like a cheap kind of violent shoot em
up type thing
they wanted to transpose the action to
the modern day because it's cheaper to
shoot than a period piece so they wanted
to set it in modern day kansas city
um instead of like in the book where
it's 1945 to 1955. but when they brought
coppola on he was like absolutely not we
have to do it exactly like it is in the
book and we have to shoot it in new york
city
uh at which point like the producers
like nah because that's very expensive
and very difficult you know what i mean
because you know traffic because the
traffic and everything it's like a
nightmare you can't clear out the scene
of anything modern and another thing too
is that they wanted to shoot as much in
little italy as they could in new york
city
and ironically is this i don't know if
this is irony but the mob
actually controlled a lot of little
italy at the time and did not want them
filming the movie there because there
was like this whole thing about like the
what it was like the italian american
like civil rights thing where they were
it was actually again ironically like
run by a mob guy who said he wasn't a
mob guy but he was
and they were like um they protested a
lot of they're like look we we were
tired of like all these movies coming
out and making us all look like
gangsters and like the stereotypes and
everything it had like a lot of members
like 800 000 people or something like
that
and so they were basically like we don't
want like another
mob film coming out and the producer of
the movie what was i can't remember what
his name was i saw like an interview
with him earlier but he's like he had to
actually go and meet
with like mob bosses
and say like they and like he had to
give them the script and they had to
like
charm them yeah and basically and they
the weird thing about it was like he's
like i took the script and it was like
120 pages or something like that and
he's like so i take it to the guy and
the guy's like looking at it and he's
like like he obviously was too lazy to
like read the whole thing
and um he was like well they wanted him
they wanted him to take out the word
mafia yeah and they're like weirdly the
word mafia only appeared in the script
like one time maybe twice
um so they're like okay fine whatever
we'll take that out and he's like and
you have to take out anywhere that says
um koza nostra yeah um and they're like
it didn't even say that and they're just
like you're done okay yeah and it's
funny because
there was like [ __ ] going on so like i
said the mob absolutely did not want to
make this they were doing like
shakedowns on all the kind of like shop
owners in little italy like they're like
we don't want the people filming here
and they were like doing this big
crackdown but ironically like after the
movie came out
the [ __ ] mobsters loved it of course
and they said like all the guys like
they were working fbi like undercover
like with the mob and everything they
said after that movie came out like all
the mobsters started acting like the
mobsters
was like they're all emulating those
guys it was like so funny but like even
in the middle of when they were shooting
this like they were literally shooting
this like four blocks away
when the guy that was that like the
mobster that was the head of the italian
like civil rights thing was like gunned
down yeah you know like four blocks away
from literally like where they were
shooting this
so it's like [ __ ] crazy so there was
like an actual like mafia war going on
just a few streets away from where they
were filming this at the same time but i
just thought that was so funny that like
the mob was so dead set against we don't
want well you know and they and they
would do [ __ ] like um like a couple of
like the producer's wife i think she
said you know we came out like they'd
shoot out like the um
the windows of their cars and [ __ ] like
that they would do [ __ ] like that yeah
well there are people like any other
bomb threats they're people like any
other people and uh people like status
and
to them that made them feel good and
increased their status that they'd had a
place just you know when they saw that
movie uh you know they kind of created
it it created a heritage for them
something to live up to it's funny that
you know like one of the greatest
[ __ ] gangsters of all time has been
john gotti and he talked his way into
the [ __ ] mob
he wasn't a mobster he was just a tall
good looking guy who knew everything
about the mob and liked him and started
hanging out in bars where the mob hung
out in and he talked his way into a
position of a [ __ ] dog
but according to people that were around
at that time they said he was like jfk
he would show up and make them feel
important
you know and
then and then over a period of a few
years telling guys you know what they
should do and what they shouldn't do and
then the next thing you know he's in
charge
because that's what happens in the
natural order of human beings
you know talked his way into the bomb
yeah
slasher fred uh has a has a fun fact
which i'm glad you're reminding me
because i probably have forgotten to
mention this but
uh the scene with the
the christening like with their where
they're christening the baby like when
michael corleone's plan is going on
where he's like shooting all the other
like spoiler alert
when he's like taking out all the other
uh mob bosses or whatever that baby was
uh sophia coppola
and you know what i
i feel like i knew this at some point
but then forgot about it talia shire who
plays connie in this who's like the
sister of michael in them
that's francis ford coppola's sister in
real life i had forgotten that talia
shire was francis ford copeland's sister
well because he's all he's you know he
puts his um family members into a lot
like not
usually like in big mane roles or
anything like that but a lot a lot of
the extras and stuff like that and the
funny thing about it the guy that plays
luca brasi in this um he he was an
actual
mafia hitman
yeah yeah he looked smart yeah
and they and they said it was hysterical
because well an enforcer that sort of
that's what they call it they said it
was hilarious because
um they said he looks great and they're
like yeah he'd be he'd be perfect for
this because they didn't cast that part
until like right until i think after
they'd already started shooting the film
and he turned up and they said so he's
like a hitman and they said he turned up
on the set and he was so [ __ ] nervous
about being in the movie they said you
know the scene at the beginning at the
wedding where he was sitting there like
reciting like what he was gonna say like
to veto they're like that was just him
rehearsing and they just thought it was
funny so they put it in there
because it was like they said yeah
that's like what his character would be
like because he's like really nervous
about like meeting but they said that
was actually him like repeating his
lines over and over so i thought that
was like kind of cute but they said that
was so funny that he'd like probably
killed people for a living and yet was
terrified of being in a movie that
character uh from the book is pretty his
backstory is [ __ ] pretty wild too
the backstory that he was basically the
devil you know that he was [ __ ] bad
he had some irish
girlfriend that he'd had his in this
[ __ ] really horrible relationship
with and got her pregnant when the baby
was born he took that baby forward and
threw it alive into the furnace
and i think she killed herself after
that and then he was then he kind of
went on a suicidal rage and tried to get
into fights and tried to get tried to
get people to kill him for [ __ ]
months
and a young don corleone [ __ ] saved
him from himself basically and turned
him into
a torpedo
but that's a good backstory
it is yeah they don't really but i mean
like i said i don't remember a lot from
the book i feel like there was a lot of
stuff i remember the book being good but
the thing about it is that i think the
movie kept just like exactly what needed
to be kept from the book
and took out like all the extraneous
stuff because i remember that there was
a lot of like extraneous
like stuff going on in the book that
probably didn't need to be in the movie
yeah but i don't know it's been a long
time since i read it but i do remember
there was a lot of stuff going on in
there that wasn't there it was kind of
smutty wasn't it what's that the book
the book i remember the book had like
was yes but weren't they talking about
like one like one chick's like loose
vagina or something yeah it's been a
long time i was i was a teenager
i seem to remember something like that
so i was like okay
in this in this book about mafia but
yeah like i said i was probably like a
teenager like in my 20s when i read it
so i don't remember but i just remember
there being like a lot more stuff in
there than was in the movie but in the
movie like even though it's
i think that i don't know like
we watched it last night it's 2 hours
and 55 minutes but then i see other
people talking about how it's like two
and a half hours but now i mean it's two
hours and 55 minutes but like i said it
doesn't really seem that long no it goes
by fast it goes by fast because it just
like moves and it's not um it doesn't
have to over explain anything like i
said it jumps ahead in time but it
doesn't like hand hold you about it it's
just kind of like this is what we're
doing now and they just kind of like
keeps
moving along and it kind of trusts the
audience to
know what's going on yeah there aren't
any dead spots in the movie no
absolutely not it just keeps on moving
yeah
and as i said that's you know yeah
there's a lot of other stuff going on
and there's a lot of characters and
there's a lot of like grudges and [ __ ]
like that you have to keep up with but
it remains like pretty focused on
michael's story like you know what i
mean like him sort of going from i don't
want to get involved in this to being
like the head of everything like over a
10-year period and so i think it's good
that that's kind of like the fulcrum
that the story
you know kind of
coalesces around i suppose yeah but you
know there there's that
i was going to say something else too
but i forgot what it was oh um
yeah so the thing about it was that
al pacino this was nominated for like a
[ __ ] ton of oscars that year and for a
long time well this was the top grossing
movie in 1972. there was [ __ ] lines
around the block to see it people were
seeing it multiple times it was like a
massive cultural
uh you know phenomenon pretty much and
for a long time i think it was the
highest grossing movie ever i don't
remember what knocked it off the the
perch but
it was like the highest grossing movie
for a really long time
but it was nominated for a [ __ ] ton of
oscars uh it one ended up winning three
including best picture
al pacino was mad because and i think he
didn't show up to the oscars that year
because of it because he was just
nominated for best supporting actor
even though ostensibly he's the main
character i think he is yeah i mean he's
kind of the main character yeah and
that's kind of how he saw it because i
think that marlon brando was nominated
for best actor he's been but he was more
of a supporting character but yeah but i
don't think he wasn't in it as much
because like he it wasn't really that
far into the movie before he got shot
and then he was kind of like he didn't
die until later but he was in the
hospital he was in the hospital most of
the time just kind of like laying there
so i kind of feel like al pacino
probably had a legit beef yeah because
he's like hey i'm kind of the main
character yeah when you're talking about
the godfather you're not necessarily
talking about even though everybody
calls vito corleone godfather
you're kind of talking about michael as
well like his sort of like going up the
ranks yeah they were both the godfather
right so that's what i'm saying so i so
i can see why al pacino was mad because
he's like well i'm not i'm you know he's
the main character but yeah i think like
all i think the three of them i think
james khan was maybe nominated but yeah
this kind of [ __ ] in a nominee i'm
surprised it only won three but you know
thank you again zach zach zach why did i
say zak i don't know
what the [ __ ] i was trying to say like
two words at once i think i recall
reading at one point they wanted a
mermaid man from spongebob himself
ernest borgnine that's right yeah um
when it came down to it it was marlon
brando
was who coppola wanted and the studio
wanted ernest borgnine to be the
godfather which i think he would have
done all right i think but um
they are they or i think george c scott
was considered
but
like i said they really really seemed
like and coppola in particular really
seemed like he wanted italian-american
actors instead of having right so you
know you might have had a thing with
like
like you had with fire starter with like
george c scott being like a native
american but yeah so they did and you
know it was nice they had a director and
stuff like that and they kind of like
filmed it in most of the locations in
real locations
uh where the [ __ ] would have been taking
taken place and the the scene where they
have um
where they kind of show
uh you know although mafia wore like
with all the newspapers and stuff like
with all the photos
um a lot of those were real
like photos of of mob hits and you know
who edited that or put that together
george lucas
george lucas put that together oh and i
wanted to say too the very famous horse
head scene
uh because you said yeah that looks like
a real horse head it is a real horse it
is a real horse head um you got that
from the slaughterhouse they got it from
a dog food factory
so yeah i mean it was a horse they were
gonna kill anyway sadly but yeah
although a lot of times they die or
they're euthanized [ __ ] like that they
go to the dog food factory i mean yeah
that dude must be like a real heavy
sleeper i don't know i don't know if you
could put a bloody horse head in my bed
without me waking up and being like the
[ __ ] are you doing all right
i kind of feel i was looking at that
head was a little bit smaller than that
than the head on that thoroughbred you
know what i mean it was well yeah
obviously it wasn't the same horse
they're not gonna like kill that like
six hundred thousand dollars
it wasn't a nag but it wasn't a [ __ ]
top end 60 thousand dollar thoroughbred
either yeah well they're like you know
it's close enough
but uh yeah the cabbie from escape from
new york is veto hello yeah yeah or the
guy with the ghost yeah he's reigning we
saw him in the rain he played a real
he's a real good villain ernest borgnine
can bring it when it comes to beating
now some peop some people pointed out
because i said he must have played a
villain he was in so many [ __ ] movies
he must have played a villain at some
other movie and a bunch of people
pointed out that he had been in uh
what's that movie called bad day at
blackrock i think it's called there's
like yeah he's a villain in that as well
yeah but i kind of feel like most of the
time he played kind of more affable yeah
sort of characters
uh but yeah so it's nice to see him play
a bad guy it would have been interesting
i don't know i mean ernest borgnine
might have been good in it but i don't i
don't know if it would have had the same
gravitas no
yeah
like i said the producers did rando made
this movie official yeah that's that's
what it is the producers didn't want
brando like i said because at this point
i mean it's you know
this was before apocalypse now and uh
last tango in paris and all that and so
this movie the success of this movie
actually kind of
made marlon brando like
like hot again you know what i mean like
to be in movies because prior to this he
was getting like a lot of shitty yeah
you know he was on his kind of downward
trend like i said he had a reputation
for being kind of difficult to work with
yeah
yeah so the studios didn't really want
him because they thought he was a pain
in the ass and what francis ford coppola
he wanted him so bad
that he's the producers like well maybe
if you do a screen test and couple is
like i can't ask marlon brando
to do a screen test so what he did was
he snuck over well he didn't sneak over
it but he came over to marlon brando's
house and he's like hey do you mind if i
like film you doing this scene it's like
i need to test some equipment
so he got him to do that
to to do like the part and then like he
slipped that tape like into the middle
of like all the other ones like the
producers and brando saw through that
well i'm sure he did
but
but i'm sure he appreciated well i like
that he didn't want to like insult me by
asking hey so he's like so he just went
along with the ruse i'm sure
but they kind of like so yeah so the
producer like okay then okay what it was
is brando says like they don't want to
ask you for a screen test pick one
because they know that it's beneath me
and two if i if a part doesn't come from
it they're not [ __ ] slighting me i'm
not getting played yeah so they gave
they gave him an out and an end
simultaneously that's yeah so that was
like a good way to play it
brando was was stupid he knew he you
know he was smart he crazy but he knew
how they worked yeah but crazy and smart
are not mutually exclusive he's smart
and crazy in fact a lot of a lot of
smart people are crazy yeah because
they're smart you could be talking to
brando you could be talking to brando
without warning the [ __ ] just
kiss you on the lips and you're a man
you're a man and he kissed you on the
lips and he hold it i love you
i love you too brandon
because that's so what are you gonna say
that's the only thing you're gonna say
oh [ __ ] you don't have a choice not
really not at that point strong78 said i
just had a funny thought imagine keanu
reeves as vince
vito corleone
oh my god
yeah i don't think that would have
worked i don't even think i don't even
think uh george c scott would have been
right for it too boisterous or something
about that i mean he would have been
good in it too because he always plays
like a real like a good villain but like
i said he's not italian and
i don't know i i really i really kind of
like respect the
the commitment to like verisimilitude
that they did it's like yes we want it
to be a period piece we want it to be
set in new york city in little italy we
want as many italian-american actors and
in fact they like i said they had real
mob guys in the movie because they had
to get mob permission to film at a lot
of those locations so a lot of the mob
guys were kind of like well hey can we
be in the movie or like it would be
extras and they're like sure why not so
they let so a lot of people at the um
you know at the wedding scene and a lot
of people in the backgrounds those are
actually people you know high and low
level like mob guys that want to be in
the movie and it's funny because when
the movie came out the mob guys got mad
because they didn't get invited to like
the big premieres and stuff because
they're like well they'd been you know
having the mafia war and like shooting
each other up and everything so
obviously they're like well we don't
really want to have them at the premiere
because who knows what the [ __ ] is gonna
happen so they got upset because they
thought they were gonna get free tickets
and everything so they had to like do a
premiere just for the mob guys so they
could just like go see the movie
there's somebody mentioned it um that
this was saddam hussein's favorite movie
it was this is he he liked this movie
and the entire series um
saddam hussein used the godfather series
um
joseph stalin
and uh the third reich as his blueprints
on how to get power that's that those
are his role models adolf hitler [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] joseph stalin and the
corleones
yeah he said they used him as [ __ ]
training manuals
the thing about it though is that this
is a lot of people's favorite movie yeah
so
i don't know if that really has much of
just saying that this is saddam
hussein's favorite movie i was like yeah
no it's just an interesting it's just it
is yeah dang because uh i think it would
be more interesting if you said saddam
hussein's favorite movie was like
some i don't know like chairman of the
board with carrot top or something like
that like i'd be like well that's
fascinating at how
how saddam came to power he used
elements of all those all three of those
yeah
there was something to learn from this
movie and uh did the books and the
series
you know
saddam lived in a time before you know
[ __ ] the television miniseries like
what was the one with the other one uh
he probably would have liked breaking
bad and uh what was that other one
[ __ ] the mafia in there this is
pronounced sopranos you probably like
that too
because uh you know this is very
long-form storytelling for the day three
hours that's a long [ __ ] movie
yeah back in the day you know they
didn't have these big long
[ __ ] mini series like you have now
where they can [ __ ] go into a subject
in depth so it was a lower information
world back then but still this movie
stands to test the time it's well and
again i think the producers were
expecting something more like a like an
action movie and when they saw like the
first scenes that have been shot were
like the opening scenes with all the
people coming in like the undertaker
coming in and like asking vito you know
asking the don about you know i want
some justice for my daughter she got you
know raped by these two guys or whatever
and it's like this low light dark kind
of scene that's really really long and i
think the producer's like this looks
like an art movie dude it's like i
thought we were gonna do like a violent
kind of so he added a couple like
violent scenes like that one scene with
um with uh talia shire like pregnant
connie like with her husband like
beating the crap out of her like
throwing all like breaking all the
dishes and stuff they added that because
they're like look there's an action
scene okay you happy now shut up but um
you know and a lot of people get shot up
in this like sonny gets shot up and like
[ __ ] you know veto gets shot up it's
you know there's a lot of
action kind of scenes but they wanted
something more like
originally they wanted something more
like but i'm sure they shut up like
after this movie pretty much
saved paramount studios because it made
all the money and won all the oscar well
it was nominated for all the oscars it
only won three
uh jake adams says uh goodfellas is
better than godfather yeah well that's
not better it's just a different movie
yeah it's kind of different i mean
i mean goodfellas is [ __ ] great
they're both great but they're different
yeah they're different the time period
is different and everything it's just
it's just different although i i enjoy
them both yeah i do i enjoy both i do as
well
um yeah and so casino was good
man i love cassie cause it was good too
that was the one i saw in the theater i
don't think i saw i obviously didn't see
uh god find them theater because it came
out the same year i was born but i don't
think i saw goodfellas in the theater i
thought i might have but i definitely
saw casino in the theater
um i saw um goodfellas at the theater at
camp greaves uh korea on the dmz that's
where we saw it and we watched it for
like two or three nights in a row we
kept going back to watch it because it
was free
he was just playing for free we had a
theater it's a movie theater and
everything
they'd play that [ __ ] thing two or
three times a night and we were going to
it [ __ ] two or three nights in a row
to watch that thing
it was good on a military base just us
you could drink in there and everything
drinking in the movie theater you can
drink at our movie theater yeah you can
they even have their own bar you can
yeah
no they were taking a bottle though well
yeah that's yeah well i mean you can do
that now you just need a big purse yeah
what is that bar called amc mcguffins
it's too expensive it is it's kind of
expensive 10 bucks a drink and the
drinks are kind of well that's
that's what they a lot of them are at
clubs but they are kind of weak but i
can see why because they don't want
people like running around like
chimpanzees
yeah definitely just like just water it
down a little bit because
you know uh jake adams said i know it's
good for uh authenticity to have actual
mafia in the film but their mafia i
don't think they would behave yeah i
think that's kind of what they were
afraid of
um especially because like i said four
blocks over there were actual
there was actual like mafia shootings
going on like while this because this
was 1972 there was like a lot of
violence going on in new york city like
mob violence it was all kind of like
crazy [ __ ] going on
and first power 100 says thing is marlon
brando isn't even of italian blood but
knock the roll out of the park
interestingly i had forgotten marlon
brando was only 47 when he uh shot this
and i saw some looks a lot older well i
was just gonna say the reason he looks a
lot older is because they put a [ __ ] ton
of makeup on him okay because i saw like
a before and after picture he actually
looked pretty good like he looked quite
young right um you know he looked like
he was in his 40s but he looked good
still yeah and then they showed like the
after so they did actually put a lot of
like heavy makeup on him and i heard i
don't know if this is true or not but i
heard that the reason that some of the
scenes with him are so dark in the movie
is because they were trying to hide how
much makeup was on him because they
wanted to make him look like an old man
um even though he was only 47 and didn't
really look like an old man like you
know what i mean this was taking place
of course in the 40s and 50s goodfellas
was later you know it was like 70s i
think that even went into the 80s didn't
it
um
the truth of the matter is you can go
back to the 20s with the bootleggers and
some of these italian crime families
that were happening even back in the
roaring 20s
and not all those guys were italian in
there and a lot of them were mixed
italian irish mixes because then you
know
racial admixture has been going on in
this [ __ ] in this [ __ ] continent
forever thousands of years and in the
american period [ __ ] just because of
immigration everybody was kind of mixed
so but you know if you looked at
goodfellas you know what i mean it's
when you start getting into the 70s and
80s a lot of people are
are not going to be pure italian
because they're gonna marry in white
people
yeah you know [ __ ] um
michael was getting ready to marry a
you know well i was calling on white
they're all white [ __ ] um diane
keaton yeah
i think we would just call him the irish
you know the anglo anglo-american type
anglo-irish germanic american type
people
you know you go to northern italy they
look like germans anyway
you know jake says i like goodfellas
outsiders perspective on the mafia with
uh ray liotta of r.i.p he's his irish
character more so than the overall
family driven plot of the godfather but
they're both great films yeah i kind of
feel like a lot of mafia movies
please forgive me or please correct me
if i'm wrong but i think i think the
godfather was kind of the first one the
first
movie about the mob to show it like from
inside and to show it like more nuanced
i kind of feel like maybe after it came
out francis ford coppola got
a little bit upset that a lot of mob
guys really were into it because he's
like well i didn't want to make it seem
like i was glamorizing it he's like i
was just trying to show it as
realistically as possible while sticking
to the book
um and just show them as like nuanced
characters not just people yeah just
people and like they had reasons for
doing what they were doing and stuff
like that and i don't think it
glamorizes them
at all um you know what i mean but
yeah there's a mis there's a
misunderstanding about the ethnic ass
aspect of this there's a
misunderstanding that that you had to be
italian to be in the to be in an italian
crime family you didn't
you just
in most of those families you just
needed to be italian or sicilian to
become a made man
which is different all right you
couldn't be killed if you were a maid
man without having some kind of a sit
down between higher up people
um
anybody else was kind of like in the
mafia if that you want to call it but
they're like
soldiers or employees
they don't have to be at italian blood
this had to do with who was made
and who could become you know a head of
a family or a don type deal you know
then you then they're going to worry
about you know are you italian
and it all kind of goes back
to the
to you know the moorish occupation of
italy that's when it
the once the kind of moors
occupied italy for a while the italian
government had to go underground all the
[ __ ] land owners the dons you know uh
landowners that owned plantations and
farms they became kind of an underground
government and that's where it all
started
that underground government survived the
moors and ended up in the more modern
era during the era of mussolini they're
still operating as an underground
government
kind of like feudal lords
but yeah what i but i think that
probably this was the first one that
showed the mob
maybe from like the inside perspective
rather than the outside perspective
maybe that maybe there had been other
ones but i guess this was like the first
kind of like blockbuster film to do that
i kind of feel like before movies about
the mob was usually from
somebody that was just coming into it or
somebody that was like
a cop that was like infiltrating it or
like fighting against it this was kind
of the first one that showed like the
intricacies of what was going on inside
and was massively massively massively
influential i mean
there was so much
mafia stuff that came out like after
this like this is directly responsible
for like sopranos and stuff like that
and all the gangster movies that came
out before somebody pointed out uh jake
said yeah this is a funny trivia about
it too i love it the cat in the opening
of the godfather was just some cat on
set that just like wandered in there and
it looked good in the scene best part
was brando edema like cats so it zeroed
zeroed in on him yeah cat can tell a
person that don't like cats he's like
i'm going to go climb on this
[ __ ]
it's like hey don't you like cats and
like cats i'm going to get your [ __ ]
first said
jake's also saying that yeah that was
kind of like the mafia glass ceiling of
whether or not you were italian or
cecilia yeah you know they're you can
only go up so high
if you weren't italian yeah zach also
pointed out there was actually a
controversy where the score yeah that's
right the score for this movie was uh
nominated for an oscar
but when it was discovered that the
composer had reused some of his score
from like another movie like on this
score they actually like took it out so
yeah that was uh i saw that on the
wikipedia page but yeah i mean i kind of
feel like even if you haven't seen this
movie
you've seen this movie you know what i'm
saying it's just so
filtered into it's just one of those
movies like
jaws or something like that where it's
so filtered into the cultural
consciousness
that i feel like even if it came out way
before you were born or it's like even
if i just feel like because it's been
parodied so many times because it's been
um because it's been so influential on
other movies and other tv shows and
stuff like that that
it's one of those movies that i kind of
feel like everybody needs to see at
least once just if you're
just because it's such an american like
a like an iconic like american cultural
artifact yeah it's a must-see you got to
see it yeah it's just one of those ones
and i don't say that a lot about a lot
of movies um because most movies you
know even like really really great ones
you know yeah you can see him or not but
i kind of feel like if you have any
interest at all in
film or in american art or american
culture like pop culture as a whole then
yeah you definitely in my opinion this
is the apocalypse now of gangster movies
it's it's at that level it's the star
wars of gangs or movies
yeah yeah i mean
absolutely yeah absolutely
uh so yeah so like i said we are gonna
do because louie uh very very
nicely gave us all three of them like in
the in a box set there's at least three
there might be four is there three well
there's one that's called coda which is
kind of like um
it's it i don't want to say it's like a
prequel it's like a it's like a
sequel-ish kind of thing i think but i
think it's called like the death of
michael corleone okay so it's kind of
like an extra thing
um but yeah that's on there as well
so we will be getting around to those
but i'm gonna say tomorrow we'll we'll
probably live stream at six like usual
but it'll probably be a sidetrack show
because we're going out tonight so we
won't have time to like watch the second
one so we'll probably watch the second
one maybe like
monday night
and then talk about it on tuesday but
tomorrow we'll probably do like a side
tracks because
you know like i said we got to go out in
a couple of hours
and we won't have time to like watch the
movie tonight yeah jake says it's one of
those movies that's a remote dropper if
it's on tv i stopped changing channels
yeah it's kind of one of those
um let's see
all right so i guess we've been going
for like almost an hour yeah and we
should probably like you're gonna start
getting have something to eat and like
start getting ready and stuff like that
we're gonna head out in a couple of
hours probably but yeah thanks everybody
for dropping by on this sunday have a
good rest of your weekend have a good
memorial day tomorrow if you're
celebrating it like i said we'll see you
tomorrow at six o'clock we're gonna do a
sidetrack show so we'll see you guys
then
bye